uh listen I've seen the first six
episodes of season two my only complaint
is I couldn't see seven through ten
good to know yeah thank you so you both
get to do very cool things this season
um what are you actually allowed to say
nothing
so difficult
um
I can't wait for you to see seven
through the final the final three is
that three that you haven't seen now
four yeah it's in her contract they get
to remove a finger every time we make a
slip up but it has to be interesting
though when uh it's hard to do press
when you are you know the the hands are
tied behind your back but um listen the
second season is ten episodes uh which
of the ten is your favorite and why well
it's yeah I have a clear favorite paper
too and I have a feeling it's the same
one as ansons it's gonna be episode nine
but we can't say anything yeah
[Music]
um obviously we can't discuss but um
I think they'll probably be announcing
something about it soon possibly anyway
uh yeah we obviously can't say anything
about it you know we took some big
swings genre wise this season and um uh
we really got to play hard this season
and yeah
uh so we're pretty we're pretty it's
like season one but bigger and better
and uh we're pretty excited about it to
share with them and what's cool about
about doing things
um about doing really uh about taking
big risks which are at the same time
maybe things that Star Trek has never
done before is that uh the level of
excitement it brings to the cast is
amazing like when we were doing that
that episode that we've been talking
about episode
that was towards the end of the the
season shoot when everybody is
is tired you know it's that penultimate
episode usually where really people are
is when you do the final episode
Everybody's like okay we're almost done
but an ultimate episode can be tough to
get through but we were because of the
nature of the episode and what we were
doing we had to rehearse on weekends
and when people were coming in everyone
was genuinely excited to be there lying
yeah it was so exciting which was
um I've never seen that before and all
my days is doing television and uh yeah
it was it was really it's it's it came
together
even better than I'd hoped I'm just
gonna throw a Hail Mary uh it makes me
think maybe some of this episode is a
winner well we couldn't tell you if
you're right or not
because then we'd lose fingers right
exactly you are far afield my friend
so listen now one of the things of the
season a lot of people are looking
forward to I believe it's episode seven
which is your lower decks crossover
episode
um what was it like being able to cross
over with that show uh because I didn't
see it coming and it's just a cool idea
yeah it was when uh
it when Akiva and Henry first told me
about it
um
I it's one of those moments where you
you sort of smile and Nod your head and
in inside your head you're going oh no
they have lost their minds and because I
immediately was picturing something like
Roger Rabbit right
um but once they explain to me the
concept I was like oh
that is such a smart way to do it uh and
and I don't I I had met and spent time
with Jack before and
um and had spoken with Tony before so I
was really excited to have them on the
set and they didn't disappoint and we
they were really smart to bring Jonathan
Frakes in to direct that episode
um he really added a lot to it and he
also really I also know Jack and Tawny
fairly well because my husband's on
Lower decks and uh they had some
adjustments to make having come from an
animated Star Trek show onto our set I
mean they even I think there's even they
even address it in some of the dialogue
they sort of had to adjust their energy
level a little bit it was an interesting
um it was interesting watching them and
they're so brilliant both of them I mean
two of the funniest people I'm so
talented so funny
um but watching them come in and make
little slight adjustments so that it
still felt within the correct world was
interesting yeah and and also like I
have to say it's really it's really
tough
in a lot of ways uh being a guest star
on a show that already has its its
wheels turning and it's you know it's
it's tone in place and
um you're kind of hoping you're not
disappointing anybody but they really
came in and had like full ownership over
what that they were doing and which you
have to with comedy especially because
you know comedy
comedy is comedy is more of a living
transformative thing at the moment of
doing it and then and Tony and Jack both
have great backgrounds and improv so
they were really able to play with a lot
of the stuff that was given to them I
mean a lot of it was taken off the page
and they would do different completely
different things in every take it was
really fun to watch yeah that note I
gotta stop I'm just gonna say congrats
on the season can't wait to see the rest
have a fantastic day thanks